bonjour voilà je me présente je suis
Franck Sanson je suis responsable de
l'agence immobilière réunion immobilier
nos locaux se situe à saintcltiild nous
sommes à proximité des de canons c'est
donc dans nos locaux que nous recevons
principalement tous nos clients nous
sommes une petite équipe jeune et
dynamique notre ambition est de pouvoir
donc assurer les missions que les gens
nous confient à savoir la vente ou la
loocation des biens dont il dispose les
maisons les appartements les terrains
euh nous sommes constitués d'une équipe
de quatre personnes une secrétaire donc
un responsable donc de la gestion
Monsieur Christian Gombau un responsable
des ventes et puis un commercial qui
s'occupe principalement du secteur
weest alors comme toutes les sociétés
immobilières nous avons beaucoup de mal
à recruter à la Réunion notamment dans
le domaine commercial nous recherchons
donc des commerciaux jeunes ou moins
jeunes peu importe qui nait pas
forcément de de bagage ou de
connaissance en immobilier mais qui
veilleent vraiment vraiment s'y atteler
d'autant que nous ne demandons aucune
formation si ce n'est à minima un bac et
de savoir s'exprimer correctement en
français le CRÉO est évidemment un plus
hein puisque nous travaillons à la
Réunion mais ce n'est pas le fait de ne
pas parler créole de parditoire nous
cherchons simplement des personnes qui
veulent vraiment s'investir travailler
en tout en sachant que c'est pas parce
que on travaille pour son compte en
étant agent commercial indépendant pour
une pour pour une enseigne pour pour une
agence que l'on travaille moins que les
autres he bien au contraire euh nous
recherchons des jeunes et des moins
jeunes qui aient donc une envie de
travailler une qui a comment dirais-je
l'envie de travailler en équipe l'envie
d'apprendre pourquoi parce que notre
société se charge donc de la formation
dans le domaine de l'immobilier
évidemment les postulants seront plus
appréciés s'ils ont un petit bagage
commercial que nous serons développés
avec eux voilà ce que nous recherchons
avant toute chose donc des gens
volontaires qui veulent vraiment sortir
donc de la position dans laquelle ils
sont en recherche d'emploi et qui
veulent intégrer une une équipe jeune et
dynamique dans le domaine de
l'immobilier nous nous chargeons du
reste